salut francis veber heureux de vous
avoir
or le dîner de cons d'après votre
fameuse pièce dont qui sort demain avec
jacques villeret thierry lhermitte
daniel prévost francis huster alors le
producteur d'avoir fraudé avec ford a
vendu absolument le producteur c'est
alain poiré ça on savait qu'il aimait
beaucoup d'avoir tout votre trac
beaucoup aidé dans les années 70 ensuite
il avait acheté les droits
cinématographiques à la lecture de la
pièce mais la musique vladimir cosma
alors comment mais je connais pas j'ai
rien contre monsieur costa mais comme en
1998 peut-on encore demandé des musiques
de films vladimir cosma quand on a
l'habitude
si je peux l'expliquer c'est par un goût
musical dans la mesure où il sait que
moi j'ai pas beaucoup de goûts en
matière de musique c'est à dire que je
suis dialoguiste et quand on met de la
musique sur mon dialogue ça c'est un
corps étranger donc ouais mais c'est
vrai qu'il m'a fait la musique du grand
blond avec une chaussure noire c'est
vrai qu'il a fait la musique de la
chèvre oui il a fait logique de doom et
film alors là c'est un monsieur claqué
l'âge mais en dessous moi je vois son
nom depuis six ans 8 ans sans fil dont
il doit avoir il doit avoir lundi mira
la cinquantaine je crois avant à peine
oui oui parce que comment ces jeunes à
la confond avec joseph kosma à l'auteur
des feuilles mortes en fait joseph kosma
est mort depuis 30 ans le maire fait que
ça doit être ça parce que c'est pas
possible je vais essayer que ce mât de
père en fils alors le film moi je les
vues donc je peux dire ce que j'en pense
je me suis marré je trouve d'abord qu'au
début j'ai pas vu la pièce un pour dire
franchement
au début quand j'ai vu arriver se snobe
de l'ermite je me suis dit ouh là là ils
vont se moquer des imbéciles vont se
moquer des pauvres et où ça va être
terrible donc jeté des assez énervé
quand j'ai vu qu'on voyait pas le dîner
pendant tout le film était vachement
content bien entendu et je trouve la fin
extrêmement émouvante dont on rit
beaucoup et la fin c'est très bien ça ça
formidable enfin si vous avez
différentes a pas mal de compliments sur
le sujet mois par les deux vous ça me
fait plaisir rien de plus
non j'ai trouvé si vous voulez qu à la
fin moi j'avais une petite larme à
l'oeil quand il ya la dernière scène
entre pignon donc alors on va regarder
un extrait qui ont continué la
discussion magnéto je viens de vous le
dire juste leblanc
le blanc c'est son nom et c'est juste
son prénom monsieur pignon votre prénom
à vous c'est françois c'est juste et
bien lui c'est pareil c'est juste bon on
a assez perdu de temps comme ça ma femme
à signer leur demande son nom de jeune
fille christine me guirec
bon elle est bretonne je vous en prie
rester concentré excusez moi vous
n'oubliez pas enfin de conversation vous
lui demandez où vous pouvez joindre
christine de direct ça se jouerait sur
haut parleur
je prend l'accent belge non alors
alors oui c'est au monde alors dit dans
ce film il a coûté 92 millions de francs
alors ils sont où les 82 millions de
francs parce que bon vous vous en vous
en prenez une partie j'imagine la plus
grosse partie et c'est moi qui j'espère
vous nommez la tour eiffel derrière
c'est pas la vraie tour eiffel non mais
c'est plus cher
ah oui bien sûr c'est une vrai que vous
avez fait construire une 4 tonnes et
demie c'est tissandier le décorateur
hugues tissandier qui a voulu il a eu
raison donnée à l'appartement quelque
chose de entre guillemets gigantesque
pour enlever la claustro du thé a
retrouvé hier
et donc j'ai effectivement le luxe
d'avoir une tour eiffel merveilleuse et
c'est fantastique parce que moi on a
l'impression de ses appartements du
champ de mars lie la tour eiffel qu'on
pourrait toucher de l'alcool de 82
millions dont un sérieusement le temps
le temps d'accord le temps c'est très
cher au cinéma le temps et comme je
voulais donner un rythme au film pour le
dé théâtralisée on a beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup travaillé au niveau des prises
mais terrier de faire quelquefois 30
prises avec les acteurs on en parlera
après de façon vous êtes un maniaque
vous pour ça que ça marche alors la
pièce faisait 2h20 vous avez fait un
film d'une heure vingt donc c'est bien
ce que vous disiez mais c'est un vrai
film quoi je dis il n'y a pas de super
on sait pas du théâtre filmé elle est
allée des gros plans qui rendent sa
beaucoup plus spectaculaire je vais
rajouter des choses comme l'accident
oui et puis c'est la première que ce
film en scope ce qui est bizarre parce
qu'avant j'ai filmé pendant le jaguar
quai où il ya des paysages amazonien
merveilleux bgta 85 et là justement
parce que le scope c'est le format idéal
du cinéma j'ai fait du scope pour la
première fois dans le programme mon film
plus intimiste et de voir le
visage de villeray sur un écran de 24
j'ai découvert que c'était des paysages
extradé vers lés visages un gros plan en
scop est un acteur c'est aussi
intéressant sinon plus que les chutes du
niagara on admire leur talent de très
près alors c'est pas facile d'adapter
parce que vous aviez fait l'adaptation
vous allez beaucoup d'adaptation que
ceux ci on commence à parler de tout ce
que vous avez fait en 1 min mais vous
avez fait l'adaptation de la cage aux
folles pour le pour le cinéma et vous
vous disiez vous même d'ailleurs que le
film était moins drôle que la pièce
c'est difficile non acer que dans le cas
de la cage aux folles c'était difficile
déjà parce qu'ils ont changé l'acteur
ils ont pris tonia dit qu'ils étaient
italiens et qui a joué en italien en
face de ce héros en français il avait
signé le contrat pour jouer en français
tony a dit quand il a vu que ce héros
était tellement bon ouais
elhadi joue en italien il va hélas trop
tard ce qui fait que ça à des rythmes et
le film et puis en plus la pièce était
une pièce d'acteurs la cage aux folles
ce qui fait qu'ils aient des traditions
tous les soirs et la pièce pouvait avoir
une demi heure de plus certains soirs
voyait donc le film qui était obligée de
canaliser et de contraindre tout ça a
été à mon avis moins drôle que la pièce
obtient ou telle complicité entre poiret
serrault chez eux mais en revanche si
vous voulez j'ai fait l'adaptation de ma
propre pièce l'emmerdeur lourd ni draaf
joséphine qu'est ce que le contrat et
s'est vu la mère de leur verdeur et là
je trouve que le film est meilleur que
la pièce est de la même manière le dîner
de cons c'est mon adaptation sur ma
propre graisse et ma propre musique
puisque c'est moi qui ai mis en scène
dans ses thèmes on dit qu'il a mise en
scène au théâtre voyait donc j'ai
retrouvé la distance si les marques je
suis beaucoup plus un scénariste qui est
un auteur dramatique mais toute façon
vous dites aussi que les pièces peut
faire de très bons films et une pièce où
on a on a en commun d'aimer beaucoup
spécial dernière de 1,2 benech qui
s'attaquent de front de paige pas un
billy wilder et qui est une pièce au
départ et qui qui est devenu un film
formidable jack lemmon génial
alors vous faites une tournée en ce
moment effectivement un peu
promotionnelle en province et il paraît
qu'un type qui a demandé est ce que vous
serez pensée a tiré une pièce de votre
film c'était alors la l'éclat de rire
dans la salle et vie l'hermitage il lui
a dit qu'est ce que vous faites pour
dîner mais alors il paraît que spielberg
a demandé là une cassette donc doté de
faire un remake de sa non c'est pas ça
s'est pas passé comme ça spielberg a vu
le film au ranch à pacific palisades là
près de los angeles et il veut faire le
remake c'est bien qu'ils sont en
tractation maintenant avec gaumont vont
ils réussir à s'arranger au balancier
rien mais en tout cas spielberg veut
faire le film comme quoi quand vous
envoyez la pièce à new york personne en
veut et quand vous faites le film était
intéressé en le casting c'est un
spécialiste en tandem pour un nouveau
film c'est toujours un tandem avec
depardieu évidemment avec pierre richard
pour la trilogie la chèvre fugitif et
compère brel et ventura dans l'emmerdeur
est un spécialiste en film d'hommes ou
départ ils sont pas mis à prix
deviennent amis un scam votre truc ça
oui en tout cas c'est ce que j'avais
mais puis les c'est drôle parce que les
références que j'ai dans le cinéma sont
faits les films que j'aime sont les body
stories des histoires d'amitié
je pensais la traversée de paris avec
gabin et bourvil
je pensais à midnight cowboy oui pensez
à larnack butch cassidy oui c'est vrai
oui oui est une comme ça y est tout un
tout un genre du film il ya deux élèves
dans la comédie le corniaud et la grande
vadrouille de funès bourvil c'est aussi
fait pour que vous n'êtes pas pris
brasseur il trop vieux et écouter ses
cruellement disent que vous venez de
dire en fait et il faut que l'acteur le
site le cinéma est plus réaliste que le
terrain on peut imaginer effectivement
sarah bernard jouan l'aiglon à 60 ans
ouais mais là un homme de la génération
de brasseurs qui était épatant au
théâtre un qui joue au dîner de cons à
la soixantaine ouais pas beaucoup
depardieu qui était pressenti était
d'accord puis un moment ça s'est pas
fait non parce qu'il était vraiment
vraiment vraiment fatigué il avait fait
normalement cinéma il n'en pouvait plus
d'occuper mes lhermitte lhermitte le
fait très bien dans votre carrière j'ai
commencé par faire des études de
médecine ensuite
rtl vous avez écrit des nouvelles vous
avez écrit évidemment beaucoup
d'adaptation et de dialogue pour le
cinéma on peut pas tous les citer
le magnifique une histoire formidable si
l'idée de vous le magnifique oui bien
sûr magnifique vous pensez que brocade a
un peu massacrés à la réal non bah oui
parce que j'ai retiré mon nom ouais ah
oui j'allais pas mis votre nom j'avais
signé les riques peut-être que j'étais
un peu violent à l'époque parce que le
film tient à peu près le coût si vous
voulez mais de branca qui a un style de
cinéma bouffonne ans et les acteurs
jouent comique
oui c'était pas du tout ma musique
vous ce que vous dites aux acteurs
toujours c c'est à moi d'être comique
toi tu joues ton truc et puis c'est moi
qui m'occupe que ça soit comique c'est
lorsque vous dites au sujet de des films
des frères du caire la 2d sli nilsen qui
n'est pas en fait qui n'est pas
quelqu'un de très comique sérieux et jeu
sincère il joue sincère et c'est ça le
truc
or les jaguars ce bon ça a bien marché
ça fait 2 millions et demi d'entrées
enfin pour un film qui a coûté 115
millions ce prénom + le pactole comment
ça se fait là d'un seul coup on a dit
webber nous fait de la métaphysique et
tout qu'est ce qui s'est passé on
attendait passe à la gta meunier
effectivement passagers moi le sujet
m'avait touché mais je me suis rendu
compte que c'est un peu enfantin si vous
voulez comme sujet je suis pas rendu
compte que un sujet de maïs peut passer
pour un sujet bête
j'aime beaucoup à voir mais on m'a
reproché de faire de la métaphysique
dallemane à un peu et je peux pas lutter
contre le jugement là je pense qu'il ya
éventuellement ce problème et puis on a
vu le tandem n'était pas à fonctionner
pas aussi bien que d'habitude entrerez
nous ébranle aussi c'est très difficile
de juger un de ses enfants c'est pour ça
que oui moi j'adorais le savoir parce
qu'en plus c'est le tourner ça a été
formidable
oui puis c'était un beau jeu lire les
paysages venezuela tout ça alors aux usa
vous avez fait deux films donc le remake
de fugitifs avec nick nolte ecafé
effectivement 45 millions de dollars
sont pas mal et welcome to boost chaud
alors là vous avez pas fait le scénario
et c'est une catastrophe
en fait pourquoi faisait partie désunis
parce que la critique était méchante
avec vous en france non non non non je
suis parti parce que j'avais fait trois
films à plus de 20 millions d'entrées
sur paris oui j'avais l'impression
d'avoir way à découvrir autre chose
c'est là qu'on m'a proposé d'y signer
m'a posé des consultants sur scénario
c'est très flatteur vous rencontrez 400
berg michael eisner et où ils vous
disent de venir là bas vous ai fait deux
films en ces temps on peut prédire que
et vous ai fait beaucoup travailler vos
amis américains et vous dites on devient
pas américain à 53 1 50 ans à l'époque
c'est vrai j'ai un peu douloureuse pour
vous non non parce que j'y suis toujours
oui je vais faire un film ben là bas
c'est dire mais c'est vrai que c'est
deux fois plus de travail
dire que ici je suis chez moi oui et
c'est plus facile mais là bas on dit
anémie greta l'homme qui a tout perdu
sauf son accent là bas effectivement que
je m'habitue et je m'adapte bien les
exécutifs zaba c'est terrible mon dieu
oui dit comme un torero qui s'est fait
encorner un peu quand même hein
gitans cornet foncez c'est plus poli
bien des trucs qui passent pas présente
les sentiments vous dites lâcher plus
dans lequel de vos films la petite fille
tombe amoureux du personnage au départ
le fugitif
enfin ils comprennent pas pourquoi la
petite fille tombe amoureuse loi est
rationnel n'ya pas d'anti héros alors
que nous c'est de çà fait notre devoir
de toujours avoir une rédemption à la
fin c'est des trucs on n'a pas la même
psychologie ça c'est vrai vite que pour
réussir à hollywood les seuls qu'on
réussisse et ceux qui avaient fui le
nazisme ya ça parce qu'il s'était brûlé
leur vaisseau sur vous vous saviez qu'en
france on vous attendait donc c'est vrai
pas mal ma malchance c'est de ne pas
avoir hitler ici mais ça va venir
oui oui c'est en train d'arriver vous
êtes obligés de vivre ce dernier vous
allez réussir pour de bon cette fois je
file tout de suite alors on disait que
sur le plateau est une sorte de
réincarnation de clouzot vous êtes un
tyran intégral elle vous fait faire du
jogging alors j'ai lu ça vous faisiez
faire du jogging à 2 par dieu à pierre
richard vrai vous envie avec eux
remarqué mais pour leur faire perdre des
kilos
c'est terrible ça surtout à depardieu
parce que ouais une époque où il avait
tendance à huy à avoir plus de kilos qui
n'ont fallait en particulier dans sous
le soleil de satan lui et l'abbé bâche 1
avec l'ascétisme du personnage et 130 kg
ça pour l'acteur qui l'est pour faire
passer ça alors effectivement qu'on me
disais tout à l'heure donc vous c'est
vous le sait vous le boss sur un plateau
et vous reprenez cette phrase de billy
wilder
j'ai mis ces trois ans écrire cette
phrase et a peu de chances que tu
trouves venu en trois secondes c'est une
bonne phrase ça c'est un truc que je
vais ressortir quand je vais parler au
patron des patrons de chaînes de télé
alors les meilleures comédies vous dites
sont basées sur des sujets dramatiques
c'est à dire toujours un regard décalé
sur quelque chose de dramatique cirque
en fait quelqu'un qui se prend les pieds
dans le tapis
c est drôle mais si son fils est
suspendu au balcon c'est beaucoup plus
fort beaucoup plus fort si les
présidents des etats-unis s'est encore
plus fort ouais ouais il faut que ça
soit et décalées comme vous le dites
huawei et puis des concepts artificielle
ne suffisait pas peur par exemple vous
dit certains l'aiment chaud ces deux
types qui s'habillent ont fuit pour
jouer dans un orchestre et il jouait
c'est c'est effectivement au début un
truc complètement vous partez toujours
de dinde un concept de la wii d'un
postulat passionnel d'être artificielle
non c'est pas grave si vous le rende et
petit à petit réel oui le gros travail
c'est ça en fait ces données du réalisme
un truc qui au départ peut être un peu
absurde quoi vous êtes fort c'est un
vrai nancy si vous êtes
c'est un boulot quoi mais alors vous
travaillez beaucoup énormément vous
écrivez si l'on tout petit comme ça vaut
sénart et si vous dites jamais été très
doué pour la vie et si j'avais plus
aimer la vie j'aurai moi écrit c'est sûr
pourtant vous aimez luxe il paraît que
quand vous arrivez dans un hôtel voulait
la meilleure suite que ça n'a rien à
voir vous pouvez très bien être très
heureux dans une chambre de bonne
nous sommes alors dans une très belle
suivre je dis pas que c'est très
malheureux mais quand je dis que j'ai
pas doué pour la vie ça va pas dire que
je n'aime pas la vie mais ça veut dire
que je suis plus à mon aise que je suis
réfugié dans ce que j'écris que quand je
dois me cogner au monde et c'est pour ça
que j'ai fait en 30 ans 25 films et 4
pièces
oui c'est que j'ai pas arrêté j'étais en
face d'un mur j'ai créé en face d'un mur
et je repartais avec korean à se mettre
en face d'un mur blanc pur c'est ça
campana et perrin le nom de tous mignons
pignon aussi a toujours un pignon vous
préparer quoi alors je fais une comédie
j'ai créé une comédie en amérique en ce
moment pour la tournée en amérique en
france ah bon ouais ouais
à vous dégoûter non je ne lâche pas
vous êtes toute une génération daniel
filipacchi était un peu comme vous sert
des deux gens pour qui l'amérique
représente beaucoup de choses et qui
finalement voulait réussir aux états
unis choix de la génération d'après
finalement pas moi j'ai dix ans - que
vous quoi pour nous c'était moi
important d'aller réussir aux états unis
fait vraiment dans une génération qui
veut marquer là bas c'est vrai tout
simplement on a en a eu cette génération
peut-être moi sûrement l'impression que
on arrive aux championnats d'europe le
champion du monde se passe là bas
est ce que c'est vrai ou pas parce que
l'on peut très bien faire un champion du
monde dans son propre pays vous à dire à
qui l'on fait et moi j'ai eu cette
espèce de fantasme et je continue à la
voir notre salut bonjour merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de in a l'habitude
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux